ordena las expresiones según el
los valores pueden responder a cualquier numero
de tetas y en la categoria o deja un
categoría vacía
así que hemos estado grabando aquí y
tenemos estas tarjetas que tienen estas
expresiones y se supone que debemos
clasifíquelos en diferentes grupos solo en
tratamos de ganar aquí y mantener
la longitud del segmento debe estar sobre el
longitud del segmento bc cuando estos
expresiones exiguas y entonces deberíamos
expansión en arrastrar allí grupo apropiado
para solucionar esto les dejo red bull que
este problema y mi pequeño blog señala el
pizarro una granada o como le quieras llamar
fuera de la hierba de kim es el mismo diagrama
un poco de apelación aquí son las expresiones
que tenemos ya sea a través de los grupos y aquí
está en los grupos por lo que deberíamos más tarde
expresiones que son iguales a estas
expresiones primero para escribir todo esto
tener tu momento así
sobre la altitud es el segmento bc
pensemos en cómo te segmentas
entonces el css está aquí porque vivo aquí
sobre longitud segmento bc sobre
largo y todo es todo aquí es uno de
segmentos de un triangulo
Claramente soy un triangulo triangulo
abc y por reggina en la competencia lo para
que bielsa que triangulo triangulo abc
estudia este triangulo que podemos
imagina esos lados
uno de sus ángulos y nos lo mostrarán en el modelo
de los angulos y aqui en el 10 estaremos en este
ángulo de ataque y anotó con el narco
aquí allá el narco y la cacería y otro arco en
en todas partes hay yo soy el hito
sera un angulo de 30 grados
así que aquí también hay 30 graduados
aqui solo de los arcos que son de 41 grados
solo de los arcos aquí he terminado
grande es eso
estreno jueves - desde 41 grados
estos son tres arcos y nos dijeron
cuantos grados simboliza este pavo
ángulo con tres arcos es congruente con
este ángulo
con los tres a cosec de todos modos
este triangulo marion es triangulo abc
sabemos que la medida da este ángulo con
30 grados
pronto en el andamio alrededor como si
relacione el ángulo 9 30h lado así
podemos darle personas y casos y pcs
hipotenusa de este ángulo recto y tomando
como referencia los 30 grados
es igual al lado este sobre podemos
el escribano por nada
solo para recordar para saber si es ese sonido
de un ángulo se supone sobre potencias a
un ángulo se basa en usos de energía
entonces quien es el condado y pierde escribo
este el coseno de 30 grados
será igual al distrito adyacente uc
así que xss
c&a se trata de ella que podemos darle todo
exiguo t
así que si estoy aquí es lo mismo que
lo mismo que con 130 grados porque el
hacemos un seguimiento de iai
Estoy aquí este es el caballero de 30
graduados
Ahora veamos el siguiente ángulo de este
ángulo de este estado de s
desde entonces si que este ángulo de
ataque
andrey cuatro organos aqui para quien
confundir así que este es el ángulo de s
Me quedé con ellos y coseno dts baño uno
cada vez más ecocine 17 basado en
poder porque se quedó sin ángulo de ese
el texto es ese estudio de ac dc y eso no
ya se sentira bien y que todo saldria bien
segmento y si entonces la hipótesis menos la
la hipótesis es tan lejana en el futuro
poder en san y poder ese lado de at
t lo que quieras llamar no y surgir que
todo lo que podemos escribir como
v y ahora aqui algo mas e igual
esto se debe a que no vemos esta opción aquí
no tenemos ninguna razón en estos acerca de cómo
una opción aquí qué pasa si tenemos qué pasa si
tenemos aquí es esto en los ángulos aquí en el
mezclará 41 grados y la razón de esto
lado verde sobre este otro lado como
sería si queremos aplicar en las funciones
bono de trigonometría a esther gullo
en relación con este ángulo de gobierno es este
lado opuesto y adornar la rana à unl potter
nosotros a as que en relación con 41 grados
inscribir el éxito relativo a 41 grados
se propone sobre los poderes a ser
cocinado desde este ángulo pavo este año y
este ángulo desde aquí no se supone
sobre potencias que soy igual a 100
el resto es igual a la de 41 grados
este y si es aqui son 41 grados
el extremo cesa el grupo apropiado de
ángulo
ahora que este angulo de cd
tenemos dónde estás ángulo
este ángulo aquí es cómo puede castigar
un montón de arcos aquí para mostrar que
es diferente en los temas que este ángulo
por lo tanto estamos tratando con este triángulo
estupendo
estamos viviendo con este grand grand
triangulo que todo aqui
esto recuerda que se supone que la calefacción no debe terminar
usos de energía que se están poniendo en can
el as que se aparta porque todos los
ser base es c c cual a en el rito de caa1
sobre la hipótesis en el saque sabe sobre el
tz1 sobre además nos vemos como un
opción aquí para pensar que podemos expresar
esto en la relación económica aplicada a
algunos de los otros ángulos en los 11 modelos
anglos
'wow en este ángulo desde aquí podemos llamar
nuno de assis e integrado al relativo a
este ángulo de qué lado estamos
tomando la razón por la que ahora estamos tomando
asunto relacionado con este ángulo de
reciente sobre la hipótesis
así que si se trata de la hipótesis de
ángulo de 30 años reciben este igual a la
de este año es que en cuanto estos sean iguales a
este que deja las vigas de noviembre
este es igual que el de ahi y pude ver que van de
tía civil nombre iso y quiere que nos un
pero tenemos algunos que simplemente podemos
prestar emote supera a y
usaremos el tricolor que todo da
el segmento a es este chasquido que todo aquí
déjalos drogarse pero está ahí en los ojos de
segmento a sobre el aborto tiene segmento y
pepe en la altitud del segmento hebe
fue que esto es p
esto es a partir de ahora estamos enfocados
somos 100 enfocados en este triangulo
este triangulo es el que todos conocemos aqui
como este ángulo desde aquí tenemos
arcos de dólar
tenemos costos de arcos de polarización aquí y estos
y 41 grados porque si tenemos marcas
dólares aquí
entonces seguramente serán 41 grados
por lo que el relativo a este ángulo
corte este viernes y si en el puesto sobre
sobre la hipótesis de la publicación sobre poder usar
estado aquí base l ds ángulo 1941 graduados
igual que este primero aquí porque
queremos ser es 41 grados era igual a
41 años si de verdad nos sentimos bien
espero si ganemos